okay for people joining this live stream
sorry we're starting a bit late again um
the this is about array operations
and it's a little bit of a mind-bending
subject
and etienne has provided something which
he is initially claiming is going to
help us
unscramble our understanding here so
let's start off here okay so
we are talking about so different kinds
of things that can happen here
okay okay so this is
array that first thing i i to a rule j
that's already supported right yeah and
that swaps two levels
yeah this is kind of the same question
and this is maybe more of a jose
question
um tensor diagrams
with creatures with legs you know like
penrose tensor diagrammy type things
are those useful in understanding what's
going on here
um i'm not sure
okay could we invent question i mean i
don't know whether it's useful but
could we invent a diagrammatic in a
sense
diagrammatic notation for some of these
operations
i think for example i think i would
start by trying to express the notations
with indices
that might help rather than numbers
right right right right but i mean then
things like
uh you know there's various operations
like there's taking a trace
you know which is basically gluing two
two legs together
there's transposing which is basically
exchanging two legs
there's um
yeah i mean we should write this out i i
think we should write it out
in terms of indices we've got some
operations here like flattening
which is not an operation you normally
do with tensors
am i correct right so
the fundamental operations with sensors
are tensor product
tensor contraction and transposition
and those are easily expressible with
indices
but flattening is not anything related
to array reshaping is not
that easy well but that operation
array reshaping i mean curiously in the
physics project we have some examples
where we basically are doing array
reshaping
which turn into these weird
space-filling curves in branchial space
and all kinds of weird stuff like this
but it is basically a ray reshape it is
essentially flattening
there's another point to make which is
that if you think about what something
like
map thread is doing and i think map
thread is the tip of a vast iceberg of
of flexibility that we haven't figured
out how to
index properly right if you think about
what map thread is doing it's kind of
it is very similar to a tensor
contraction in that
you know you've got two tens two things
with legs
and you're saying i'm going to match the
first leg of this guy and the first leg
of that guy and walk over them
simultaneously
so i think there is maybe a connection
with tensor diagrams but it's just
it might be quite a sophisticated
algebra that we haven't yet worked out
so i i i do have a way of map thread
though
go ahead so i was going to say that
i do have a way of expressing threading
operations via indices i haven't thought
about
um legs
what is the yeah i mean let me look for
it i can send you something
okay okay all right but let's okay
i just wanted to raise that because i
think it might be useful and i
i take i mean tally is making the point
that map thread
arguably any tensor operation
i mean map thread is doing one
particular
end tensor's you know contraction
operation
and what i think kelly might go ahead if
you scroll down a little bit
i put something about map thread just in
explanation
in terms of dimensions that's kind of i
i
yeah it was helping me understanding all
these things
so this if you say map thread
these colored pictures these colored
pictures are quite
quite nice thanks
so if you say level two what it does is
that it always takes the first level so
map thread
i mean at least in this current
specification always take the first
level
and then put it somewhere so if you say
level two it will actually put a level
two plus one
and then it applies f starting from this
level
to to i mean at this level effectively
so
so on the arrays that are at this
uh level right
so i mean i guess i guess another thing
is you can kind of just think about it
it's collapsing the tensor in some
dimension right it's like it's like
saying uh
uh yes right so
in fact you can say you can say a little
bit more precisely you can say so go
back
to my legs business you can say you've
got a list of these
objects they've all individually got
legs
and when you say comma n you're saying
i'm going to take the nth leg of each of
these objects
and feed them all simultaneously into a
function that will
combine all of those guys produce one
result and that eliminates the leg from
all of them so the results will have
the resulting expression that comes out
of map thread
will have i'm not quite sure if it's
what legs will it have well i think what
you're describing there
so let's talk about how tensors work and
you know
in standard tensors you you know you you
simply
apply an operation like summation to
covariant contravariant indices
right so what we're doing here is we're
generalizing that and we're saying you
have an energy operation to combine
indices
to combine elements right so that's the
first generalization
um and
there may be other generalizations but
that right there is going to change
tensor calculus so to speak
yeah i mean it's clear there's a
calculus of what's going on here and
did jose did you find your your indices
analysis
or um i'm about to send it to you
okay okay okay but let's let's go back
um let me just save this file so that i
put it in a reasonable place um
let's see let's call this
okay all right let's go from the top of
etienne's thing
now yeah this transport was just a side
thing because it was making it easier
to express or reduce and and also this
level applied that
that you were talking about last time
okay
oh boy this is okay this is the whole
notebook but the only thing we are
interested here is this lambda notation
so this is the algebra i i invented to
do these things so this this is
annotation this is an algebra
that has the global idea of contraction
and can implement
map thread out in all these functions
can be expressed in this notation
so i see so your lambda here is a
generalized
tensor is a is an n index
contraction is that right where the
where the combiner function is g
exactly and the yeah
we could have list some table etc
this is a nice notation right and then
if you go
to for example contraction of several
arrays
and go to map thread
and lambda annotation
so that would be the expression in this
language
okay so hold on so you're saying nth map
thread here
is
when lambda doesn't have a g on top
means list
okay that so that's kind of like a
transpose i guess
if there's no g on top
yes if you want transpose would be re
reordering the indices
so what this is saying where does it
insert them it takes these indices this
lambda takes these indices and where
does it put them
so these means we are going to have a
number of indices
of list levels around the whole thing
so that's what that's going to be an
array of that depth
those are the indices of this resulting
array
and the elements are going to be f's of
arrays
no i understand that but in this pure
lambda here
right the that takes these or
as i understand it what it's doing is
it's saying take a trace
over these indices here feed them into
i'm confused about what this is
returning so it's returning an array
of those n levels
which are which which have indices p 1 p
n
then each of them at that level there
are elements
f of arrays and then the
the traces are in the repeated indices
which are the p uh yeah p1 pns
i'm slightly confused but um my gosh
what is this
these are other notions of of
contractions and array operations that
i had explored with roger
and this is the conversion of these
things we are discussing into graphs
by by the versus conversion by these are
the tensor indices or something is that
right
um we are working with sensors
uh for indices and those are the
contractions yes
so this is a representation so a ternary
so something there's an in degree in an
out degree or not is it like you take
n indices and you're combining them
and is it should i think of it in the
following way
that this uh
that there's a like an f at every node
here
and that you're taking certain edges
here
that are incoming incoming edges
combining them with the f and then
sending them out to some outgoing edges
is that right or is that the wrong
picture
so there are two types of edges here and
and i think in some of the diagrams i
use different
styles so some are the edges forming the
tensor
and then there are other edges exactly
here
edges contracting the various indices of
the tensor so here we have two tensors
which are the two black boxes and they
are contracted
to in pairs right yes
and so we see still two three uh
levels or slots or indices which are not
contracted
in the first diagram
i'm still not completely landed on
what's going on here
i mean i think the a question is
is this really a story of um
uh
you know okay let's go back maybe to
etienne's
discussion here and see what i mean i'm
just
okay so attend you were we were talking
about transpose
what is that new notation here i goes to
j or is that an existing notation
no it's not an existing thing but it's
something i thought was
could be useful uh so it's taking level
i
removing it basically i mean or axis i
don't know how to say it
and then put it in in position uh j
so it's uh it's a way to define a
permutation
cycle in a way which which is useful to
express a re-reduce
and um yeah
well if i can just endorse this so this
is actually
it's it's very useful when you know that
you have something at a certain level
and you want it at a different level
because otherwise you just have to
you're forced to kind of doing the
mental calculation of
what the permutation is that does that
and that's just
i mean you can obviously work out the
permutation that does that but why
force people to do that it's easier to
just for them to think
well something's at level three but it
should be at level two and then just go
three arrow two
why is that different from swapping
those two levels or am i totally
confused because the order doesn't
change so
check this example the dimension where
three four five
six and i want the three to be at level
four but six i don't want it to be at
level one
i want it to stay next to the level i
see i see it shifts them
through each other so just it keeps
bumping the three to the right to the
right
to the right and that turns out to be
actually
much more yeah i i wouldn't say that
this doesn't change anything else it's
changing all the indices actually
right so what this is doing is this is
replace
part which is saying replace
no this is not replace part this is this
is the inverse where it's saying
take level one and put it at position
four
no it's i mean it really is the same
thing it really is the same thing as the
swap two levels except that
it's just what what do you do with the
you know
it's basically it's just what do you do
what do you do with the one
that was in position four now that
you've moved one to four and so this is
just you shift everything over as
opposed to use
as opposed to swapping it yeah yeah
it's cyclic permutation so why is it all
of them
why isn't that second argument to
transpose on the implementation just
rotate
right of range of depth
well maybe maybe if you move if you're
moving an indic to the left then maybe
it has to be a bit different
just probably better implementation i
did the one that
you know come and i just wrote that
before uh okay
uh yeah it's just an interesting idea
and then invest permutation so in
general
okay if i remember transpose takes a
permutation as its second argument right
you can specify a permutation as a
second argument
correct but so one thing we could also
imagine
is that you whatever specification of
permutations there are like a list of
cycles and things like that
um you know we should be able to give
that
permutation spec as the second argument
to transpose
so in other words the syntax two
arrow five means cyclically permute
two three four five that's what i think
yes
that works okay so psycho you can put
cycles in the second argument of
transpose oh
it already works yes with cycles not
with list of cycles i don't know what
that
would mean can we understand what that
might mean
so a single cycle
okay it doesn't seem to document this
oh or cycles there we go m n
okay i i think it'll be worth thinking
through go ahead
um yeah it's i don't think it is quite a
cyclic permutation because if you think
what
what one goes to four means is like or
three goes to six it means take the
three
shift it over one you know swap it with
neighbors until it ends up
at level six it's not quite as like
it's a bit of a span it's a bit of a
range cycle range
except that oh it's a rotate left
it's a rotate left not a rotator right
so exactly you take
you take that whole three four five six
and then you rotate left
and you end up with four five six three
okay so we should be able to compile one
arrow four to some cycle specification
for sure yes but it it's going to be
difficult to remember which direction it
goes the good thing of the two-way rules
is that it's symmetric
oh look at this they're intuitive to me
but
pointing out written this
function repository item about tensor
diagrams
what the heck is this doing now
interesting oh my
well this this clearly should be looked
at
yeah thank you this is kind of the
inverse operation at some level though
which which is the inverse operation the
well at least
my understanding what this is doing is
it's uh
or maybe not actually i okay i guess
maybe it's using interpretation boxes
but
i guess what it looks like what it's
doing is you give it a
an existing array operation and then it
shows you what it looks like in
tensor notation which would be useful to
us in our attempt to understand what's
going on here i suspect sure
right good very nice
what i can say is that the the arrow
syntax that we're proposing there
i disagree with jose i think it's it's
very natural to interpret i goes to j
in one and only one way which is what
was level i becomes level j
and there's only one way to shift them
over that makes any sense because one of
them is local and one of them is not
local
you know one of them each thing moves up
one level others that get scrambled in a
weird way
um and we use this all the time and then
sorry to interrupt
yeah we just use it all the time in your
network so like again
you know this is not a theoretical
exercise this is it's too hard to
express common
array permutations and acrobatics
and the place where we have a lot of
experience with that is
in neural networks they they're just
very rich in
linear algebra stuff and array
operations so
when we say something like you know this
is a useful operation
like trust us like we do what we've been
doing for years now
um it is worth having some kind of short
syntax
for that concept
explain anyway that's just a pointer
okay
tally big picture you got a neural net
and it's a deeply nested array
explain sort of the big picture of why
you're doing array gymnastics as you
connect
those deeply nested arrays together
what's kind of the way to think about
this
i i think the way to think about it is
that you are kind of
arranging various axes to be at the
at the positions they need to be so that
a particular operation that you have
available as a layer does the thing that
you wanted to do
i see and then puts things back out
again so in other words you say
you have a layer and it's expecting a
pair of levels
and now you have to connect that to the
right pair of incoming levels and maybe
maybe that does the layer often take in
a tensor of rank and
and put out a tensor of rank m or how
does that work
well it's usually some some are yeah so
often layers will
do things like there'll be there'll be
one privileged axis
which is say often the first axis or the
last axis
and then the other axis are just ignored
right
and so i have a very strong suspicion
that
um and this is not just a suspicion
people have written about this and i
think
you know their arguments are worth
looking at that the current way that
people do this sort of stuff which is
the sort of acrobatics of getting axes
to the right point
for various operations to do their thing
is going to very rapidly fall out of
fashion when better ways are designed
and one of those is naming the axes
because as soon as you name the axes you
don't have to transpose them around
you just say let me use an analogy
in the beginning of you know programming
we had registers and you'd like
you know you just said assembly language
and you could load your variables into
the
memory locations into the registers and
then you'd have operations that would
act on those registers
and it was a nightmare of sort of like
swapping things into the right registers
for this
for the instructions that you had
available to you
and you didn't name them and you didn't
you know you'd have to like reason about
at this point in the program what is
register three containing
it's very hard to read that kind of
stuff and rip
variables just revolutionized like no
one went back to using
you know okay which brings us again back
to the question of named levels
which we don't have right because that's
i mean so that would be the conversion
between these two worlds
so in other words we could imagine a
thing where we said
you know named level named i mean this
is a bad
syntax but something like named levels
of array
comma you know a b x y
okay that could represent i mean not not
a good notation
but that could represent an object which
is choosing to
call its nth level you know b or
something
yeah exactly and and then what we could
do
go ahead well that's one syntax i agree
so that's where you have names for all
of the levels in order you know level
one is a level two is b
you might also have the situation where
sometimes
you have a name for just one level like
a sparse
naming no that's fine so you say two
arrow
y or something but then the question is
then then the idea would be
if you had a named level object you
could do something like
i mean but then it's not completely
clear what you'd want to do but i mean
then you could say something like
transpose and you don't have to know
you would say something like you know a
goes to x
that would just be a renaming there
would be no need to actually manipulate
the underlying array
so i agree that that's well defined what
you've written
but i would you see the need for
transposing largely goes away
when you've got names for the the levels
just like the need to swap registers
goes away when you've got variable names
i see well although there might be there
might be efficiency things internally
when you might want to do that that is
unclear probably depends on what you're
doing
yeah yeah right yeah yeah
but you see so in the grand future which
i think eventually will dawn on us
um that'll be a compiler problem the
compiler will do
we'll look at the program you've written
and say well i know you're going to do
this out of product at this point and
that's most efficiently done with dgem
you know with blast operations if those
two things are at the top
if it's row and then column and then
whatever and that's not something you'd
ever worry about but i don't know it's
not there yet
i agree so it's basically register
allocation versus
you know it's the the analog for levels
of register allocation
yes yes yes yes right it's also maybe
there's an analogy between between
lists and associations of this as well i
mean where it's
i mean it's the same kind of thing if
you refer to with the names
as an index yeah that's exactly right
but
so i think the story that we have from
before
which was you know you can think of
associations as just taking
lists and generalizing the parts to be
not just integers but other things
i think that story now carries over
except we're no longer talking about the
elements of a list we're talking about
the axes of
a multi-dimensional object right but the
thing i don't understand is if
you know you have something like array
reduce and you've only
named some of the levels how is that
operation well defined
it will have to be all the levels name
now no
what's wrong with it i mean if i'm
re-reducing over level x
and i know that level x you know you
know
like with associations maybe you can
kind of well
i mean you can you can if one way of
doing is you can just say well level x
is actually just
you know it's actually just uh you know
level seven or something level seven
right and then you just run it over
level seven i mean i get i guess
it is i think that's very good it is a
little weird though because right
because it
is like having an association where
where you don't have all the
keys yes let me attach
let me attach the semantics because i
think i think there's a very natural
semantics for
this exact case of array reduce of
only one names level and you only have
one named level right
what it will so remember what array
reduce does it deletes
the axis that you asked to reduce like
whatever comes out will have one less
axis and the one that's missing
is the one you asked it to remove now
normally when you have numbered
indices that's all a little bit
confusing because the numbers before and
the numbers after have the sort of
complicated relationship
where some of them are the same and
others are shifted over
but when you have names levels and even
if not all of them are named whatever
one you ask to delete by reducing
it's gone from the naming and whatever's
left over is left over
i think it's like it's like a key delete
or something
in in an association
yes and i think it's easier to reason
about because with associations if you
delete a key
all the other keys have the same meaning
they had before but with the list if you
delete an index
then some of the indexes match the
indices match and others don't the ones
after the one you deleted no longer
match up
right that's why it's actually easier to
you know it's it's just why it's easy to
deal with named axes
because all of this kind of keeping
track of allocations goes away
right i mean it reminds me of a of a of
a weird thing in smp
so an smp had a combination of
associations and lists
so there were symbolically indexed lists
and it did the crazy thing
that when the list happened to can you
know have indices
that were sequential integers it would
order them
in the order of a of a you know a dense
list
that was insane but this is well that's
also the choice that
that's also the choice that javascript
made so i'm not sure
i mean it is insane but it's also a
mistake that other people have made
oh well they only did 30 years later or
something or whatever it was yeah
yeah the that's interest i didn't know
that i didn't know anybody else had made
that stupid mistake
by the way i mean one other thing is i
mean maybe one other way of thinking
about
having some unnamed levels is you know
if you had a
for example if you had a named levels of
an array
um and the array is deeper than the
number of sort of names you give
you can kind of think of it as a named
levels array
where the elements themselves are arrays
yes exactly so a very good example of
that would be something like
you have a bunch of matrices for
different countries
right that naturally shows up as a named
levels object
where it's got three axes you know it's
three rank three
um but the first axis is country it's
maybe that's an association axis maybe
in fact that's one thing to keep in mind
here is that we might want some of these
axes to not just be
integer yeah you know axes that take
integer values but also
keys right i mean this is this isn't as
going to say earlier is that
i mean more generally this is something
that that sort of
has been discussed certainly with like
data set and things but i don't think
anything has actually been done which is
kind of uh association arrays where you
don't have to
you know where it's where it's secretly
some packed object instead of it
the kind of horrible thing where you
know i i have
10 million rows and every one of them is
an association with the same key
okay so i to highlight this okay so
data sets can be ragged what we're
basically talking about
here is dense arrays rectangular
rectangular-ish arrays
is that correct yeah
although it's interesting how it can
generalize to
maybe you could have missings or
something which let you make it ragged
but
yeah right i think we should think about
it as as raggedness with missing
question mark question mark but
but right i agree so the question now is
if it's data sets
if dataset always knew it was going to
be rectangular what else could it do
right well i think it would fix a major
deficiency with dataset which is that
um this is really about the naming
rather than other things the naming of
the axes which is that
you know designing queries you've got a
reason about how you kind of step
through the various axes one by one i
know and that's because until now
our axes we only had the only way you
could talk about axes was as integers
and they were left to right
and it was sort of up to you to think
about this weird descending process and
whatnot
um but if we have these named axes then
you can just jump straight to the axis
you care about to do a certain thing
like a plot or whatever
so i think it is this whole thing could
rehabilitate data set a little bit i
mean it is very hard to use in some case
okay so question
i mean it seems though like these are
two different things though i mean
there's there's
there's i think association arrays
okay i i argue that they're probably
association arrays that are not that are
more ragged where you don't necessarily
want to name all the levels
like this what is an association right
oh i mean
something that doesn't exist but we were
talking about a minute ago which is just
the issue of
you know consider this simple case which
is
i've got 10 000 oh
store efficiently column oriented
storage basically
well right but it should be more general
than column oriented right because i
might have
three levels of nested association or
nested associations of lists of
associations and so on
and you know if the keys are basically
if it's fundamentally i guess maybe this
has to do with it
being not too ragged but if
fundamentally
it is just you know a rectangular array
of some kind then you'd like to not have
to repeat the keys a million times right
so
basically it's an erase array and then
it's a key spec
of some kind where that array could be a
numeric array an efficiently packed
numeric array and so on
so it's similar to this named levels
wrapper it's a way to basically
say how to index into this array
it isn't changing the array but it's
saying what the meaning of those
different pieces of the array is and how
you would index into it
yeah exactly the elements that was
supposed to naming of the levels that's
the distinction
yes yes yes yes right right right
quantity arrays is a
is a different aspect of the same type
of thing
this is something we talked about
earlier yeah i mean
that that there i think there are a lot
of different types of
fundamentally array-like objects running
around and i mean
right now there's i think very little
infrastructure for
you know if i want to implement an
array-like object
and i want to make sure that it works
with flatten it works with total
it works with you know et cetera that's
kind of
pain right now but that's a good
annotated arrays okay how can they be
annotated
right okay so one annotation is um
what are the indices
um at a particular level
eg association keys
another thing is um
what are the names of the levels another
is um what
uh wrapper eg
quantity is applied to each element
let's see then there's other things like
there are more complicated cases i mean
quantity array
geoposition fine but then there's also
i mean i guess that's a lot of the cases
but there's also things like sparse
array
and stuff like okay so let's consider
one more case
can we also have a data ray or something
like that
yes okay so then there's things like
data ray
geo array which i don't think we quite
have yet but those are i think those two
no no those two there's a geo position
can be given a list of geo positions and
i think data ray
i think those things are equivalent to
quantity array because fundamentally
you could write it as just an array a
normal rectangular array
with with you know wrappers applied to
each element okay but i claim there's a
different thing which is this is
saying and same thing comes up in in um
3d graphics type stuff this is saying
what is the meaning
of a particular index
configuration eg
an actual g you know eg a geo grid of
some kind
right where you're naming so so where
you're trying to spend less effort
like in a geo elevation data thing where
you're trying to say
you know rather than for every point
saying this is its geo position
you're merely giving you're giving
essentially an outer product
of two you know you're saying
okay this is indices and this is in a
sense what do the indices mean
right which i argue is very analogous to
quantity ray but
yeah so what the quantity away is about
values
go ahead wait so so
maybe you're right so maybe there are
two sides to to the annotations
one side is whether you're annotating
the keys the indices
and and just to keep in mind
that if it's part of a bigger array it
might be that the annotation really just
lives on one particular axis rather than
on the whole array
you know okay so there's that kind of
thing
um and then there's um an annotation
on the values right and that would be
something like with dates it would be
like these are all in the following time
zone and i don't have to keep storing
that so that's an efficiency thing
and it might also just it might even
sometimes be a semantics thing that you
know that it's possible to like
i don't know you might want to do it as
strings you might want to have something
which is a bunch of strings
rather than having entity wrappers
around them
yes right and about the
quantity arrays right you know if if all
the
quantities are commensurate then maybe
it's about values but if one quantity is
seconds and the other is meters
then you know you're implicitly imbuing
it with different meanings
so it's a bit of a fuzzy line
okay so i think so i have worked on all
these things so i can explain
so quantity array has us uses
rob's framework which is it's currently
called structured array framework but
it's a general array
framework it's very powerful so it could
do more things than
just structured arrays and so quantity
array works
that way data ray is planned to work
that way
geoposition doesn't work that way
because it preceded
the structured framework so we had the
opposition of arrays before the
structured array framework existed
so that's one aspect then and i fully
agree that it's it's
it will be very powerful to to program
things via that framework
sorry a second structure right now
called systematized array though
all right i just looked up the
documentation it said that structured
arrays
is no longer its name and now well
the thing here was that we decided to
maintain them
in the container in the resulting
containers we decided to keep the names
of the types
quantity array or in the future data
array because steven complained multiple
times that
it was weird to have quantity arrays
having the head structured array and so
we change that to keep the head
quantity away which i think is it's it's
a good change
okay so i mean i'll just i'll just
mention that another historical case
that could be a structured array and
probably really should have been
is sparse array it's so the struct
the idea of a structured array is that
it it represents
it represents some array but it it
it uses its own storage to do that
right i think that i think that's beyond
this is really dense not very ragged
arrays that we're talking about here
and there's a whole bunch of stuff that
can be done for dense not very regular
arrays
for structural infrastructured array is
that a does it present a kind of
api that we could use to prototype some
of these ideas because one of the
problems when it comes to prototyping is
that
there's some things you just can't
implement with up values right
there's a whole dispatch mechanism that
we don't really have in the language to
let you
create your own arrays does structured
array give us give us that
yes structured array comes with an api
for
for for doing that and and and it
defines so
you know it it defines you know it has
an api which you have to fill in
you know you have to fill in certain
things for functionality
and then when the functionality isn't
there it it typically goes back to the
normal array
um is it documented or is there an
internal notebook that we could because
i'm just
like yes i can say i can send you i can
send you the internal notebook tally
uh fantastic thank you yeah that's
awesome thanks
okay so unfortunately i'm supposed to go
to another outside meeting here
um although you guys could continue this
seems awfully productive
i mean to me this idea of an annotated
array
that allows you to you know have a
mapping for indices levels and values
seems like a good concept and then the
question is
okay so given that we can then many of
these operations can
refer to the
uh you know the mappings of indices and
levels
so much becomes it also avoids us having
to generalize various things that aren't
fully general because like
you know it's a lot of work to like make
total whatever take a
complex level spec i don't know if
that's one of the examples but you know
the various things will flatten
could you know you could say three comma
four and flatten maybe it doesn't
support that currently
but like some of the use cases for that
will just go away if we just support
you know an arbitrary index
right but because less important the
question really is
i'm still grappling with the idea of i
think tally's analogy
of you know registers versus variables
seems completely apt but the story of
that is levels now
we can we've understood how to do that
for indices that's what associations are
doing
so i have a comment there so what you
are com calling
name name the levels is what einstein
was calling indices a hundred years ago
so these are well known
yes and the problem is there it's they
are not a perfect solution they just
solve some problems they create some
other problems
the problems they create is contractions
when you have a i t i i minus t
j j you have to realize that they may
they mean the same thing
that's difficult the same problem of
lambda calculus
well but maybe the way to think about it
for us is if you've got two annotated
arrays
and their annotations are different so
this is a good question if you've got
two annotated arrays
and you say annotated array
of some array object comma
let's say i j and then you've got minus
annotated array of
array the exact same array j i
is that zero array and if it is the zero
array
with what indices is it the zero array
so so that case will be transposed that
will be the first minus the transpose of
the first
yeah you've symmetrized it i think um
well but but isn't that what it means
but hold on how do i know that
how do i know that this is now saying
this is now matching up because i
thought
this was just a local thing where these
indices were just referring to
how i were to ref was to reference so in
this case
right imagine that my index my part
specification was this
that i would to say something like um i
goes to four i goes to this j goes to
eight
and that would get me the i equals four
j equals eight component
yeah exactly yeah okay or actually more
to the point i would probably want an
association here association there yeah
and we might we might want to emphasize
strings rather than random symbols but
we could
symbols seem fine too yeah okay but so
so then this is
the way that you would extract that part
now the question is
is the ij thing and the ji thing are
they actually different
or is that merely an index you know is
it is it the case that
these two things if the raw content of
this array is the same
oh boy no no no that's still this is
actually very well defined
um so just there's an identity here
which is
annotated array because what you've got
to ask is how does it act
like when you apply when you look up
things what will you get
that's how you think about these things
and
swapping j and swapping the list
reversing the list there
uh for the second argument of annotated
array is the same as transposing
the first argument with respect to
okay so the claim is that this is
equivalent to
for i j this is equivalent to part
four comma eight right but whereas
if i were to do this to have j i there
then this is equivalent then that will
be equivalent to part eight comma four
right so when you form that sum
or that that the subtraction you're
going to end up with another annotated
array
i'm not sure what choice of
order it should have for the ji there
but we do know how it acts so
there is a flexibility i i have to sorry
i have to interrupt here
what are i and j because this looks
right i thought the point of the
annotated array is that we're naming our
levels
but if i and j are just i and j what
have we accomplished
so i is the first yeah yeah those are
the names so
what we could do in order okay
so so then so so that what so where's
four and eight
i is going to one and j is going to two
and in the second one j is going to one
and i is going to two
that's right so and and you're somehow
suggesting
that now
that plus somehow dig in
and start with the name of things but
where's the plus
what what's the plus where is there you
are you talking about this case here
yes okay i don't understand that case
here yet
that's my point i don't understand that
case that is
to me i think this is the answer to this
[ __ ] is zero
no i don't know no it's not no
this is what i showed a couple of weeks
ago in exact what exactly would do there
is simply producing a new single
annotated array which is our
array minus transpose of array comma ij
everywhere yeah no stephen so that's
well-defined but then these are indices
they're not uh
unnamed levels selling this is right
which i think is what's
named levels means like they're the same
thing
by the way we had a bunch of comments on
our live stream that are interesting
um i unfortunately really have to go to
this outside meeting
could i leave you guys to continue this
for a bit i think you're productive
uh probably more productive without me
um
so uh can can we go ahead and do that
here you can who can pick up who can who
has
access to the these um these files
devin you have access to these files
right yeah
yeah okay so um i just have to drop out
here
and i encourage you to look at some of
these comments on the live stream
they're
kind of interesting um
uh and various comments about how this
should work on gpus yeah we
we agree um all right i unfortunately
have to go but but please
continue and i look forward to hearing
what what
happened here right munch